hey what's up his Hannibal Burres I'm
going undercover on the internet and
this is actually me Twitter
yo Hannibal did you really kick Flavor
Flav on the Eric Andre show the answer's
no I didn't kick another man on the face
on television in front of cameras that's
a crime that's a salt and then Flavor
Flav got mad he's like I didn't get
kicked in the face
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he was tweeting all angry
and so didn't me and Eric just kept
leaning into it like getting Digg kicked
in the face because just cuz he got
upset
how many flicks of pickle juice will it
take to get my tuna right I would say
seven I'm totally looking hella dry and
get some better fish next so team Drake
or a team push I want to see just good
rap songs I played in a softball game
with Drake well Odell Beckham jr. he was
on our team and he had a lot of
defensive errors that cost us many runs
that didn't really make the news but I
didn't read about it so you should
respect me for that who the crap was
that guy pretending to be Hannibal
Burres at the spider-man premiere as tag
spider-man homecoming he did that
hashtag cuz he wanted his [ __ ] to get
seen I couldn't go to the spider-man
premiere because I was filming tagged
actually first thought it was just okay
I should send somebody in my place and
so I tweeted out an email address saying
hey I need a look-alike for this event
did I got contacted by somebody that was
a stand-in for me when I did a video for
the MTV Movie Award so that's a little
what Inside Edition went to this man's
house the day after where was Hannibal
why couldn't he make it hey why are you
here Inside Edition why are you taking
this so why are you it why are y'all
tripping about me not showing up to the
spider-man premiere well this is a movie
about a man that's also a spider but now
I'm crazy for sitting somebody else to
that when you
making several movies about a spider-man
alright let's go with that post it
you too Chris silver asks why does he
always sounds super baked I don't know I
don't know why I sound super beta's my
voice I'm not baked now but I had a five
milligram need meant because that's what
I have to use to get through media Oh
[Laughter]
Hannibal why oh why did you get rid of
that sexy space between your front teeth
I got TV teeth you're supposed to get TV
teeth and I said it was I had a chipped
tooth they had chipped in a fight and
there was a gap so I got him fixed up
that's why ok ass hey Hannibal my dream
is to become a famous actor so I can
play Hannibal Buress in his future
biopic could you pay for me to go to
film school please that's a that's a
strong no for me a strong no doubled up
with a hard pass and a smooth yet next
Yahoo Answers why did I see Hannibal
Burres riding a pig little girls bicycle
that's a lot that wasn't me a pink
little girls bicycle no last time I rode
a bicycle I had an air B&B in Venice and
that was part of the house so I was I
was riding there but that was not a
little girls bicycle it was a type of
bicycle and a half the weird handlebars
like this that I hate more Twitter
oh and Hannibal Burres that you ride the
bike through Venice I told you well I'll
get to ride the bike buzzes you need to
know how casual it is to drive by
Hannibal Burres on a bike that was I was
route goes right to Venice that week and
I had a bike now and I usually don't
stay in Venice when I'm in LA it was a
nice day the Airbnb I was staying it had
an orange tree I'll go and grab launches
it was a really nice time why does
Hannibal Burres look like every car
to character without their glasses I
look like solid one yeah you got yes
move 12 retweets from that yep
NBA player Harrison Barnes ask anybody
think Hannibal Burres conduct that was
about four years ago and the answer is
who knows there that now when I was 31
maybe I get excited doing it on video
games like and I and I scream on a video
game when I duck like I actually did it
in real life
Wikipedia Hannibal of mere birds was
born in Chicago Illinois on February 4th
1983 the son of teacher Margaret and
Union Pacific Railroad Jesus Christ
internet the [ __ ] out of my dad's job
please I know I said it once maybe in an
interview just cuz I said my dad's job
in an interview doesn't mean you put it
on my Wikipedia page [ __ ] weirdos he
briefly attended Southern Illinois
University Carbondale where he became a
friend of hip hop artists over my Eagle
his RA at the time I didn't briefly
attend Southern Illinois University I
attended for four years I just didn't
get the piece of paper that you're
supposed to leave with him for years but
I attended it the full time I hope I was
able to answer all your questions from
the weird insulting to the ones where
you saw a person that looked maybe a
little bit like me but it wasn't me at
all
that's it